now reggie it's been the third quarter  defense of the brooklyn nets which they  have really pointed to  throughout these four consecutive wins  and uh this is something they want to  hang their head on oh my goodness  and kevin this is his 18th season  that's what i'm trying to tell people  something  i needed a wheelchair to get out of bed  in my 18th year  [Applause]  [Laughter]  21 points on 16 shots reggie and this  he's fallen out of bounds sideways with  the defender right in his face  at the stripe 92 free-throw shooter  [Music]  oh lebron  [Music]  james  he's 36 and he looks like he's on that  cover of si that you were  showing a couple minutes ago reggie but  hold on  look at kevin durant on the brooklyn  bench